I
the pleasure enjoy he has indeed the
positive significance that
self-consciousness has become objective
to itself but equally it has the
negative one of having reduced itself to
a moment and since it grasped its
realization in the former sense only its
experiences of a contradiction in which
the attained reality of its
individuality sees itself destroyed by
the negative essence confronting it
which is devoid of reality and content
and which yet is the power which
destroys it this essence is nothing else
than the notion of what this
individuality in itself is it is however
as yet the poorest form of self
realizing spirit for it is aware of
itself at first only as the abstraction
of reason or is the immediacy of the
unity of being for itself and being in
itself its essence is therefore only the
abstract category nevertheless it no
longer has the form of immediate simple
being as it has for reason in its
observational role where it is abstract
being or posited in the form of an alien
being is thing hood in general here in
this thing with there is entered being
for self and mediation if therefore
makes its appearance as a circle whose
content is the developed pure relation
of the simple essentiality the
realization attained by this
individuality consists therefore nothing
more than this that is that it is cast
forth this circle of abstractions from
its confinement within simple self
consciousness into the element where
they are for self consciousness in other
words are expanded into an objective
existence the object then that is for
self consciousness as it takes its
pleasure its essence is the expansion of
those empty essentiality zapier unity of
pure difference and their relation
beyond this the object which the
individual individuality experiences as
its essence has no content it is what is
called necessity for necessity fate and
the like is just that about which we
cannot say what it does what its
specific laws
positive content are because it is the
absolute pure notion itself viewed as a
mere being a relation that is simple and
empty but also irresistible and
imperturbable whose work is merely the
nothingness of individuality it is this
fixed relation because what is related
is the pure essential ''tis or empty
abstractions unity difference and
relation are categories each of which is
nothing in and for itself but only in
relation to its opposite and they cannot
therefore be separated from one another
they are related to one another through
their notion for they are pure notions
themselves and this absolute relation
and abstract movement constitutes
necessity the merely single
individuality which in the first
instance has only the pure notion of
reason for its content instead of having
taken the plunge from debt theory into
life as therefore really only plunged
into the consciousness of its own
lifelessness and has it as its lot only
empty and alien necessity a dead
actuality
in the video commenting on the paragraph
just preceding this particular paragraph
number 363 I give remark that Hagel's
treatment of hedonism is probably one of
the strangest ones you're ever going to
run across and I think we can add to
that that if you took out any reference
to the word pleasure you would have no
conception that that's actually what is
considering or talking about and it just
gets a stranger in this section as well
I think it's helpful to keep in mind
what he's aiming to do here he's not
engaging in something like an analysis
of pleasure as such to show that
pleasure is not the good or that
pleasure is only you know part of the
process or something along those lines
those sorts of analyses you know you can
find them done by say Plato Aristotle or
the stoics or you know go all the way
through to the you know st. Thomas
Aquinas is somewhat a logia you know
contrite you know discussions of
pleasure in him and that's not what
Hagel's really about keep in mind what
this entire section is is this reason
right so the reason section is
self-consciousness trying to make sense
of itself trying to understand what it
is the in relation to its other which is
the the world and that is not just the
world of things you know which we were
looking at an observing reason but very
quickly becomes a world of other
consciousnesses of social cultural world
if you like so the discussions of
pleasure fit in there and let's remind
herself why did pleasure end up being
the thing that the self-consciousness
was seeking was it just looking to
escape was it engaging in
getting itself off in one way or turning
itself on as you know these metaphors go
was it just you know stimulus response
and find something that feels good to it
it just keeps on doing that and pursuing
that no it's searching for its happiness
it's gloop right it's what is going to
fulfill it you notice that we were using
this term essence and essentiality you
know vezes night here that really is you
know to make a little joke essential
this entire process self-consciousness
is has moved away from observing reason
and now it is trying to make sense of
itself in terms of its own individuality
through its actions and engagements with
the world so what does pleasure offer to
it then well that does is a good place
to go to the text notice that we've got
this reference to what he's talking
about at the very end of this section
and we begin with what he's talking
about at the start of this this
paragraph right so let's actually start
at the the end you know he says the
merely single individuality
self-consciousness which in the first
instance has only the pure notion of
reason for its content instead of having
taken the plunge from dead theory into
life has therefore really only plunged
into the consciousness of its own
lifelessness and has as its lot only
empty and alien necessity and dead
actuality so there's a couple things to
be said at that point right that's where
the paragraph is going to end that's
where all this stuff comes in this is
this section or this subsection of the
subsection is
titled pleasure and Cecily and what
we've got is in the pursuit of pleasure
not just for the sake of enjoyment but
for the sake of getting to understand
what it is making sense out of life it
winds up there's a dialectical
transformation that takes place and it
winds up running into necessity or fate
this is going to be very important
because this will lead to a transition
to the next section as well what the
person is attempting to do is to lose
and find themselves in life and remember
that for Hegel life is this plenitude
this plenum of all sorts of things that
emerged that are largely unpredictable
and follow their own developing logic
out so that is what the pursuit of
pleasure sometimes feels like and it's
it's how we sometimes depict it to
ourselves and you can think of people
who glorify the not necessarily the
pursuit of pleasure is such but /
glorify life and think of it in terms of
you know eating drinking having sex you
know sort of a naturalistic as we call
it sort of the attitude towards towards
things you know other thing of novelists
who do this think of people who write
songs think of people who create shows
and movies what the reactor is something
very hard to articulate and sometimes
they'll just come right out sit it's all
about life man and so that is what Hagel
is talking about there are plenty of
people in his own time who are doing
that sort of thing you know it's not as
if that only came about in the 1960s or
you know limited amounts of the 1940s or
though the roaring 20s or anything like
right that attitude has been around for
a very very long time why because that's
one way in which consciousness people
human beings try to make sense out of
themselves and the stuff that they get
involved in so that's that part now he
talks about pleasure enjoy pleasure is
something that we could see is happiness
precisely because we do enjoy it right
and if we don't enjoy it directly at
least somebody else talk to us about it
says oh my gosh you have to experience
this this is so amazing so wonderful i'm
willing to pay a thousand dollars for
this experience then really that person
thinks it's pretty good maybe there's
really something to that yeah if you
think about it is a bit of an aside so
many magazine so many websites are based
solely around this premise of somebody
else experiencing something and then
giving us some guidelines about that I
mean even some of the ones about the
life of the mind are along those lines
oh you haven't read it Oscar Wilde well
you you don't know what you've cut
yourself off from oh you haven't read
proofs you know monumental opus which
all have been hidin read I started
reading it and got really you know tired
of fairly quickly and decided I didn't
need to spend any more time on it all
these realms and ranges of pleasure will
offer us the possibility of enjoyment
what is that about daniel says the
pleasure enjoyed has a positive
significance what is its positive
significance self consciousness has
become objective to itself and then he
said it goes out and says but equally as
a negative one of having reduced itself
to a moment this is where the last
paragraph left off right when you enjoy
pleasure and you consider what it is
that you're in
and you try to orient your life and your
thought around that and make sense of it
whether it's a pleasure company with
friends whether it's shooting pool in
the bar whether it's you know swiping a
demonstrator on tinder whether this
white writer swipe left with swiping
until you find somebody to hook up with
them whatever sort of thing you're
talking about people engage in that not
just for the sake of you know sort of
sort of pleasure stimulus it's not just
brain chemistry they find it in some
sense meaningful but the problem with
pleasure is that it can't actually
function as an adequate vehicle for the
meaning that people are looking for in
life it pleasure is not adequate to life
you might say and so what do we find out
there's a contradiction here self
consciousness becomes objective to
itself through how it enjoys pleasure
through how it it makes sense of it in
how it responds to it yet at the same
time it also realizes that it's just one
you know of many possible individuals
enjoying pleasure it's not really my
pleasure itself that count so much
because insofar as that can even talk
about with other people it's already
become something objective and in that
sense escaped me and you go out and that
enough so he says since it grasped its
realization in the former sense only the
former sense being objective to itself
it's experience is of a contradiction
there's a contradiction a theater stroke
think of this in terms of you know very
lexical terms speaking again speaking
contrary to the pleasure itself is you
know talking to you and saying here's
what I have to reveal to you and that
something else a voice out of nowhere
you could say as we'll see why is saying
no no something something more
something less that guy's got it wrong
so what does he go on and say it's
experiences of a contradiction in which
the attained reality of its
individuality being objective to itself
sees itself destroyed by the negative
essence confronting it which is devoid
of reality and content and which yet is
the power which destroys it now isn't
that an extraordinary thing for Hegel to
say what we have here is some sort of
confrontation between the individual in
the case of his or her exploring and
enjoying and reflecting on their
pleasure and strictly speaking a nullity
and nothing he calls it a negative
essence he goes out and he doesn't just
say it's a negation or something like
that he says that it is devoid of
reality and content we're going to see
what that actually is in a moment at
this point it sounds like a mirror
nullity well this should remind us if
we've ever read say heidegger's you know
what is metaphysics other than nothing
that heidegger talks about which is
intrinsic to human freedom and Neil Asia
and all this other stuff Hagel's doing
something a bit different here though
with with it nothing so he goes on and
he says this essence is nothing else
than the notion of what this individual
individuality in itself is the
contradiction arises within
individuality within self-consciousness
it's not something that can be escaped
this contradiction is not something
purely external to it and so he goes on
and he says something really interesting
here he says it is however is yet the
poorest form of self realizing spirit
for its aware of itself at first is only
the abstraction of reason or it is the
immediacy of the unity of being for
itself in being in itself a lot of
metaphysical terminology there but think
back what was going
in the earlier part of the reason
section where we were engaged in
observation ultimately things and try to
make sense of thing good and we even
transform spirit and the individual into
a thing now Hagel says we are actually
exploring something a bit different now
thing hood has become he's putting it
here it's entered being for self and
mediation the thing is no longer just a
thing the thing is of consciousness even
the thing that we were enjoying is we
saw in the previous paragraph enjoyment
is not just of the passive thing that we
consume it also involves in some sense
the other and that other is another
consciousness another self-consciousness
so we now have a important transition
here we start speaking in some pretty
metaphorical language which is a little
bit difficult to represent in a
two-dimensional space on the chalkboard
but what does he have to say he says the
realization attained by this
individuality consists in nothing more
than this that it is cast forth this
circle of abstractions as we got here
circle of abstractions from its
confinement within simple
self-consciousness so this circle of
abstractions was within simple self
consciousness which is part of the
concrete human being who is not abstract
we had self-consciousness in real
mediated ways then it goes on and it
says into the element where they are for
self consciousness in other words
they're expanded into an object
existence so once again through and gate
let's remind ourselves what's going on
here through engaging in pleasure
consciousness got to know itself it
became objective to itself there there's
objective existence as Hagel's calling
it at the same time there's also this
circle of abstractions which is being
brought into the very heart of that
objective existence and being made
objective now you know in being made
objective it's no longer just as purely
negative essence that has known content
no reality nothing other than its we
might say bare possibility or its know
right now it should have some sort of
reality of its own contingent of course
upon the self-consciousness here's where
it gets really really interesting and I
think first before a lot of people
probably a little bit hard to follow
what is the expansion of this pure
relation of simple essentiality needs
and heightened right not just visa
essences but essential ities the you
know the being the kind of things that
are essential right well this is where
he starts talking about the category or
the categories unity difference relation
which is going to lead us into something
else in a moment but let's now go on to
there so he says the object then that is
for self consciousness as it takes its
pleasure its essence is the expansion of
these empty ascents essentially on there
he says empty right before he was saying
simple essentiality now because of empty
essentiality 'he's of pure unity pure
difference and their relation notice
what he's not saying that
he's not saying we have unity difference
in Malaysian and these are three
different things totally separate from
each other the categories you know
instead he says pure unity ryanodine
height pure difference I unterschied
right and then their relation your
bazile not cure that ryan right there is
no pure relationship right you can't
talk about pure unity pure difference
although notice as he's going to say a
little bit later on you don't actually
get them pure right you get them because
they are related to each other how are
they related to each other well buy you
no opposition to some degree which then
of course means that unity and
difference are related through
difference right and at the same time
there's a unity there which means that
there's a relation there which means
that there are certain way a unity and
we can go on and add that it's very
reflexive what's happening here notice
what else is though once we start
getting into this where's pleasure in
all of this Hagel said while enjoying
this we're somehow also involving this
stuff over here this is like totally
removed from pleasure right he doesn't
try to apply it and say oh well there's
a unity to play too there's a difference
deploy there's relation to pleasure or
anything like that even so these are the
things that arise your
self-consciousness the object that is
for self-consciousness is it takes its
pleasure its assets it is the expansion
of those empty essentiality of pure
unity pure difference in their relation
beyond this the object which the
individuality experiences as its essence
has no content so if beyond this it has
no
content then we're back to this negative
essence again that we had before so it
seemed to have some content but doesn't
actually have any content what can we
say about it here's where Hagel brings
in what we've been aiming at the entire
time fate or necessity he says it is
just what is called necessity for a
necessity faint and the like whatever
else we want to call it called fortune
call it you know the dialectical process
of history whatever you like whatever
you're going to treat as just being a
deterministic process that you have no
control over and very little insight
into that's what fate or necessity is
because look at what he says about that
he says necessity fate in the light is
just that about which we cannot say what
it does what its specific laws and
positive content are why now it's
interesting because you know he doesn't
say at this point well we just don't
have enough insight into it if our
sciences were good enough then we could
like chart out where every single atom
is and predict the future based on that
and we would understand all of that
hagel doesn't go that that direction at
all he doesn't even consider it at this
point and when Hagel doesn't consider
something it's usually not because he
didn't think of it it's because Hagel
says that's not really relevant here why
are these without content why don't we
understand what fate or necessity is
until it reveals itself to us well here
Hagel sort of draws us off in two
directions he says well on the one hand
that's because it's the pure notion we
haven't yet grasped the pure notion you
know hopefully by the end of the
phenomenon
gee we have released by the end of this
session hopefully we have but we
actually haven't at this this point this
juncture what else can we call it here
he talks about being or miller has
mirror being and remember being for
Hagel is sort of as long as you can get
right mirror being is just actuality
doesn't really have any meaning or
itself certainly not the notion but
favor necessity is something that we can
look at both as these he says it's the
absolute pure notion viewed as a mirror
being so these are not disconnected from
each other a relation that is simple and
empty but also irresistible and
imperturbable so it does what it does we
can't stop it are you know a pleasure
that we're engaging in starts to look
like something really tiny and
unimportant in relation to this colossal
Titanic necessity that is confronting us
and when we get then him saying is that
whose work is merely the nothingness of
individuality the nothingness so when
we're experiencing pleasure if we think
beyond the experience of pleasure if we
don't simply lose ourselves in that
we're always at the edge of a sort of
precipice where we can look down and see
this necessity see this nothingness see
this absurdity to a certain extent that
simply doesn't make sense to us and our
reaction might be me I'm just going to
enjoy some more pleasure not think about
that have another beer smoke another
cigarette you know have sex again watch
another show but if we start thinking
about it we start to see how unimportant
how not any answer to the question of
happiness the pleasure that we're trying
to take really is so he goes on to me
you know he talks again
and about pure sensuality is empty
abstractions is unity difference in
relation or categories each of which is
nothing in and for itself but only in
relation to its opposite and they cannot
be separated from one another notice
that we don't have you know all of these
as each one has its own opposite there
are all opposites to each other in a
certain way how can they be three
opposites well this is a triadic
structure rather than a merely dualistic
structure that's part of what makes it
dynamic so he goes on he says they're
relating to each other through their
notion right because they are notions
themselves that that is what they are
there something for us to explore
there's something for us as self
consciousness to make sense of but we
have nothing to grip onto at this point
so in trying to work through this you
know dialectic or this this response of
seeking pleasure we found our way now to
necessity and we reach that the point in
the Edward says that the myriad merely
single individuality which in the first
instance has only the pure notion of
reason for its content trying to make
the plunge into life was going to find
its meaning there or at least you know
something that would engage it now
instead here's where we can grasp the
true meaning of these words it's
therefore when we plunge into the
consciousness of its own lifelessness
and has as its lot only empty and alien
necessity a dead actuality it's now
realized that this and now the pleasure
is what is there for it to grasp in
terms of its happiness in terms of its
meaning in terms of its understanding of
itself
you